now let me ask you this so so during
that time when everything's going on and
then the movie comes out
and then when the movie comes out you
see what happens with will smith winning
the academy and all that stuff that
takes place with the slapping and then
you said something off camera about
about will if you're comfortable sharing
give give me the perspective from the
movie coming out
to then will winning oscar to then the
incident that took place what did that
do to the whole story well first off
that's a great question when i went to
the red carpet and the after party and i
met will and it was it was kind of
interesting he was more excited to meet
me than me to meet him it was kind of a
weird dynamic because you got to
remember when you're a character and
you're into someone
that deep okay and i i didn't really
understand that because that's not my
world okay um
no one had a better front row seat than
rick macy other than maybe the wife
because i was there every day
five hours a day six days a week that
doesn't sound like a lot but you go 365
days a year for four years there's a lot
of crap that could go on and blow the
whole thing up so i'm there every day
and that's why that's why i love richard
even though he was out there on a lot of
stuff so
will got so into the character when i
saw the movie when we had the screening
and mocha
it blew me away the the subtleties the
nuances the walk the talk the the
idiosyncrasies it took him two hours
just to put on how he had to look like
richard
it
it was beyond richard and this is what
i've told other people when i spoke to
him so and you gotta remember this
happened during the pandemic so
this guy was probably going into this
shopping mall he was probably going home
talking to his kids like that he became
richard and there was one
scene in the movie where uh it was in my
office in 1994
before venus was going to make her debut
all right
and i don't know it's day one or some tv
show and the guy asked venus
do you think you can win
and venus goes i know i can and then the
guy pressed her you say that so
confidently and venus goes i am
confident
and then she the guy goes why are you
confident
and she she goes because i am and then
richard blew a gasket he comes running
onto the set okay
and just tortures the guy and i'm
sitting here going oh my god what do you
mean did he assault him no no no no he
didn't assault him but he got that far
from his face he got up in his grill got
his grill just said listen leave her
alone she's a little you know a little
black girl you know
your your ass is going to be in the
ground you know she he just he blew a
gasket richard was so protective
of those girls okay
and
will even made reference of that
when he saw that
in 94. it will brought that up but i'm
sure that was discussed a lot during the
movie so now
you go through the movie and the minute
i saw it i've told other people he's
going to win an oscar even though i
don't know how that stuff works in my
opinion he was going to get an oscar
so now
when he's at the oscar
that reaction was beyond bizarre that
doesn't mean
i'm justifying it but something inside
of him
made him do that because looking back
i'm sure he wished he wouldn't have done
it because the ripples than now the
action but
maybe the guy thought he was richard
williams so that's very very that's my
take on it it doesn't justify he has to
own it but at the end of the day uh it
was bizarre when he did that when when
he got up on stage i know not that
you're a you know psychiatrist or doctor
or anything like that but you have a
front row seat to all this right yeah
richard williams venus serena will smith
you're i saw you on the red carpet with
john bernthal when he went up there and
slapped chris rock
what percentage of that was he was in
the richard williams character moment
still in it and then what percentage was
the everything that's been he's been
dealing with in his own personal life
with jada is it a cumulative effect
i mean you said that he was basically
becoming this guy richard williams
what's your analysis
yeah you know i another great question i
think a lot of it is is richard because
initially he laughed
i just think that he wasn't even
thinking i mean it was just
richard i know it's hard for people on
the outside to look at like that you
know but they become these people and uh
he even kind of said that when he was
given his speech
and but people aren't gonna say you know
that's justified but i could see that
because that was out of character to do
something like that
at that moment
when he's at the pinnacle because he's
done a lot of great things in movies
what do you think pat well you ever seen
the the moment when the uh jack
nicholson's having dinner
uh jack nicholas which one's the actor
jack nicholson jack nicholson's having
dinner okay he comes out of a restaurant
and a reporter comes up and he says hey
jack did you hear about what happened to
heath ledger what happened to him he
just he was found dead
he says what
he says yes do you remember what his
next line is no because they were both
the joker he says i told him never to
play joker [ __ ] you never seen this i
got i recall it yeah he says i told him
to never play the joker now
there's a part of that on what you're
saying that i can agree with because if
you're playing a role that long for that
much
i can see how you can take a method
actor yeah yeah i can i can see how you
can take that and become that like you
know they say daniel day-lewis is one of
the greatest actors of all time because
of the way even what's his name talked
about it ethan simply talked about it
last week where you know he gets into it
so much yeah that's like he's just a
fully a part of it yeah right and you
just you don't even know who you are you
leave daniel day-lewis when he played
the last set of mohicans you know he
went out there and lived out there to
know what he gets in it
well maybe he should have skipped the uh
maybe will should have skipped going to
the oscars that day because that's slap
change but one more point you know it's
different like if you're
in a movie and you're an actor that's
one thing but remember he was playing
a person this a bio that's that's a
little different than just acting yeah
you know what i'm saying i mean he was
an alive person too there's a difference
but there's there's
zero excuses for his behavior zero
excuse me
ever so there's no way you know that's
kind of like
saying a professional athlete who is
super super super competitive goes and
slaps like latrell spreeville of spring
what he did to his coach i don't
remember that when he coached this show
uh
choked his coach and uh you know or some
of the other stories you hear about
uh rudy tom jonovich years ago running
the other guy knocks him in you remember
the whole thing yeah the center of court
yeah yeah center court so there's no
exception larry bird who did that no not
larry bird larry bird got it maybe that
was jonathan
dr j punched larry exactly a few times
where moses was holding him back but
that's completely different but do you
think the backlash against will is
actually justified to the point where
what he did was that bad yes we agreed
not a good thing to do yeah but he
didn't beat the crap out of somebody he
didn't murder somebody he slapped
another man
so you know they're telling his will
will's getting cancelled
never again it's like this was the like
the the biggest just hollywood
blockbuster star out there i get it but
do you think it's overblown it's a
culmination i don't think it's just one
thing i think it's a combination of a
lot of different things he's dealing
with i think it's 50 80 percent of stuff
that we don't know about and it's 20 of
stuff that we know about the 80 percent
of stuff that we don't know about it
we're all speculating you know just what
we did a couple days ago with the whole
shirt free will yeah the campaign that
we put together that uh uh but anyways
going back to this you know what it is
by the way what there's certain things
that we may see and there's certain
things that rick made yeah that's right
well i think it's a no i it's a good one
uh i should use that i think it's a
medley of stuff if he'd have done that
on the street it's no big deal but
because he did it in that backdrop yes
and
you know they they have to do something
even if it's just to do something that's
what that's what's bad about the whole
thing they just have to react they can't
just say don't worry about it bro you
know it's okay uh state they had to do
something it's kind of like the johnny
depp story right you know the johnny
depp story that's going through
uh
you know with uh what's the amber ride
that they're going through i don't know
if you're following the story or not
with the two of them well he's hollywood
these days he's on the red carpet how
could he not no i'm on the court i'm i'm
going to stay on the court that's my
wheelhouse but but this whole story
that's going on and all these videos
becoming uh what do you call it all
these videos becoming like the
recordings that they're talking about
and you know everything is public
i don't even like the fact that so so
you guys chose to do the epstein case
and you did that private but you're
doing this public like it should be the
other way around that one affected
people's lives this is between two
people leave them alone and they're
getting embarrassed publicly and the
recording you're you're hearing about
you don't know what people are really
dealing with johnny depp one guy said
something he said uh in the last 50
years there's not one story of johnny
ever raising his hands on anybody right
meaning
will smith the last i don't know 30
years there's not one story of will
doing what he just did and will's played
a lot of different roles he played ali
he's going through a lot so that's a
completely different conversation if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]